guys I just got back from a hinge dates
why am I doing this to myself so we
scheduled to go to dinner we are sitting
at the restaurant seems very nice not a
catfish things are going well and the
waitress comes over she wants to take
her order and I said okay I'm gonna take
the bronzino
and he said I'm gonna take the burger
and the waitress asked him okay how do
you like your burger is that how he
likes this burger wrong do you want some
cheese on your burger and he asked is
this gonna be extra
and she says yes it's three dollars
extra oh and he said okay then never
mind I'm like okay I'm hungry I'm gonna
eat my frenzy no one see what happens
and he's like oh my God you have to pay
extra for everything these days and I'm
like yeah it's New York city so I got my
Branzino he got his Burger we were
eating
and once I was satisfied I got up
and I was like I'm going to the restroom
for a second and I took my purse and I
went to the waitress and I was like hey
I just want to pay the bill
and I just paid the bill and walks out
of the restaurant and I texted him
I texted him the check is taken care of
he should have gotten the cheese and I
brought it
[__] stupid Vlog that's her mic drop
line should have [__] got the cheese
I'm out
that's a Razor's Edge right there man
you know the anxiety she just put on a
hell of dudes now they're like
I'm lactose
oh
yeah all right I gotta get this cheese
man let me see the Stitch is this the
guy that was on the date yeah he
stitches it oh [__] hell yeah dude and
she says yes what if he told the exact
same story from the toilet no no no no
it's like word for word the same he's
like so she gets the Brunson let's get
the burger it's just not different
and then she [__] blocked him
there are two sides
he said
I had the intention of paying 21 for
this burger so adding three dollars for
cheese was not [__] worth it but
thank you for paying for dinner bye bye
okay he's a little petty he definitely
went out and got it quite why yeah that
was weird he definitely got the girl the
girl has zero argument like yeah okay I
agree that she's just mean w for the guy
but he went outside
if he doesn't want to pay for three
bucks for cheese like why is that bad oh
[__]
typical
difficult why'd you say you're broke
just say you're poor
look this is New York City I mean I I
would do it yeah yeah okay I would buy
the cheese I would get double cheese
yeah yeah it's three dollars can I pay
double can I get can I actually pay more
for that yeah can I pay nine one of the
only cheese they had was like blue
cheese and he didn't like it he was like
oh
[Laughter]
I mean yeah I don't know maybe she
viewed it as like uh oof
it's New York City
everything is three dollars more like
you have to pay for everything yeah yeah
yeah so it's like yeah but okay that's
that's fine right but then you just like
have the dinner yeah the fact that she
paid the bill left and then blocked them
yeah and then made that that's so cold
yeah and then made the tech talk well
you know is pretty expensive no isn't it
like
I thought he stopped rapping
[Laughter]
I don't know you're still making music
no what is branzino dude
the whole fish I ordered it on accident
one time let me see and yeah I had no
idea what it was I thought it was like a
meat
like a like a burger chickens ah and you
didn't like bother to ask what did you
think it was just like Italian for yeah
oh elephante I think okay I love that
that's really funny Zach going like I'll
get the princess
look at the brands you know
did you still eat it no it was it was
like a family style thing so like they
just melt some [__] pepper jack on
top what kind of what kind of cheese
American cheese
[Laughter]
like this is [__] weird
yo table 23 guys
brenzino with whiz yeah whiz we don't
have whiz he's with the nacho cheese I
don't know people know the difference
yeah
and Jackson back there like it's
definitely gonna have bread it's gonna
come between two slices and then a whole
mackerel comes out
so did you eat it that was a family
style meal so the Thompson's Family ate
it and I just had like the other [__] do
you not eat fish not a fish I just
didn't like I just didn't want it at the
time I wasn't in the mood for it right
right yeah
that's crazy order something family
Brands enough yeah it shows up and
you're like nah
[Laughter]
was my bad why would you or
I thought it was like the chicken [__]
or whatever what other word for chicken
I don't know it was close to branzino
I don't know
what language it is
saying it in an accident
just talking a babble Brent brenza now
[Laughter]
yeah I'll have it the biggest one
your [__] wife's whole family's just
eating this like did you want I didn't
want this exactly they looked down the
way
oh my God
dad all of them are trying to choke it
down be polite and Zach's not having any
yeah
why do you have a tomahawk solo you
[__] weirdo oh this isn't the brands
I know oh my bad yeah
damn dude I agree with Wally though that
guy's Stitch was kind of petty wow I was
a little why was it Petty I didn't like
that
he went out dude imagine if that girl
said that about you what would you do I
would I would be like hey thanks for my
meal it was good I I just know what he
did I would Stitch it and go
I mean you didn't have to block me damn
yeah just just Express the hurt yeah you
know why cover up yeah just go or it'll
be funny as hell if he just ditched and
said damn maybe I should have just paid
for that cheese
we were in your side the moment she
mentioned she ordered the prince prince
you know
the branzino
uh but there's no way he made the tick
tock right after no no I agree she's
she's mean for that yeah not necessary
like so what was it about that that she
thought people were gonna agree with
maybe you should have just like that he
should be a man and just man up and pay
three bucks I mean dude it's New York
City it's New York City man you just
don't get it
if you don't get it you cannot eat
expensively in New York City
if you don't want to dude it's New York
City bro have you
this is New York City we're talking
about
I didn't think about it like that
it's New York's New York City yeah yeah
yeah I thought New York you're thinking
like Brooklyn or Manhattan yeah this is
this is New York City dude come on